I really do love doing these travel
shows they have Kevin what does that
sound well it sounds like somebody
sipping something really loudly
sir what is it what's going on what are
you doing oh well well you must be Conan
O'Brien yeah the show is called Conan
and any reasonable person would assume
that yes I'm Conan O'Brien I never
assumed as they say when you assume you
make jerks out of all of us okay I'm
sorry what what's your what's your name
my name isn't important it's Gary what
is important what is important is that
it has come to my attention that you
have become quite the Globetrotter yeah
your eye patch okay there pal yeah yeah
all over that yeah okay I've been all
over the world shooting these gunner
without borders Travel specials yes oh
yes and we have something in common
for you see I am the world's most
accomplished traveler okay would you
stop sipping your cosmopolitan in the
middle of the sentence I'm sorry but I
have to you see I lost my
salivary glands in an accident resulting
in a condition called alcoholism all
right okay wait why are you here
interrupting my show why as the world's
most accomplished traveler I am here to
challenge you to visit as many countries
as I am all right okay I'll take that
challenge how many countries have you
been to eight eight eight I've been to
more countries than that list them well
if you insist
I've been to Mexico the Australian
outback Italy wait wait a minute wait a
minute those aren't countries those are
just restaurants nonsense
they're just restaurants how come all I
did those in those places was drink yeah
he's kind of got you there for God's
sake no I'm sorry no he doesn't I've
also been to the country of Kentucky I'm
a wildlife sanctuary for sexy owl okay
we get it we get it so basically you're
an alcoholic that likes to go to chain
restaurants when you put it that way
oh for God's sake get to the point yeah
I forgot what I was going to okay all
right
you've wasted our time I think you
should leave very well I'm off to
Scotland now to a little known
restaurant named McDonald okay
[Applause]
you